i spent over fifty thousand dollars on
so-called fake gurus the ones that pop
up on every youtube ad and then get
exposed by people like coffee zilla or
james janney i'm going to give you the
biggest learnings i've taken away from
spending all this money so you don't
have to
here's how i spent my money i went to a
few tony robbins events bought sam
marvin's courses got a couple of
business coaches and countless of other
small purchases well lots of it was
great so much of it is complete garbage
and because i had already built a
million dollar business using free
advice from the internet before buying
anything i was experienced enough to
understand some really shocking things
that the newbies didn't here they are
shocking thing number one 10 is a huge
success rate for a course i know a guy
who talked to sam evans personally and
asked him about his success rate and he
said 10 which is mind-blowing because
it's huge sam's course is probably one
of the best that i've taken but it's
still only 10 does that mean you only
have a 10 chance of succeeding if you
join it no if you're hardworking and
actually do what it says there's a
really high chance that you'll succeed
if you like horses that doesn't mean
that you should be a horse
don't think so linear
number two know that the bigger the guru
the more they have to dumb down the
advice to appeal it to the masters so
they can make more money even though
someone has all these facebook likes and
all these people telling them how great
they are it's probably because they have
a big customer base they market to a lot
of people and then they give cookie
cutter solutions that work for everyone
even the dumb neighbors kid that still
thinks wrestling is real product
research is the most important step of
the entire process if you pick the right
product you can do pretty much
everything else wrong and still make a
ton of money and 1.7 million people
watch this video just pick the right
product and you can do everything wrong
it's not about the product that you pick
it's just so wrong and dumb down and
meanwhile the best sellers that i know
they didn't do this at all they decided
what product they wanted to make because
they're passionate about it and they
want to serve a specific customer number
three the easier the guru tells you it
is the harder it is it all boils down to
this there's easy money there's lots of
money and there's long-term money the
catch is you can only ever pick two of
those if you pick easy money and
long-term money invest in index funds
it's very easy it's passive and you'll
make money forever but it's only a few
percent a year and you won't get rich
quickly see what fake gurus teach you is
easy money and lots of money so if you
have any success at all it'll only be
short-lived when dropshipping was new
wow it's so easy everyone can do it
we're making lots of money but because
it's easy a lot of people start piling
in it gets more saturated more
competitive and then the ones that
cashed out create courses to cash out
even more bringing in even more people
and then it gets so saturated and
competitive it's not easy anymore the
only way you should go about making
money is by making lots of money long
term
but it won't be easy so you can't put
that into an ad and sell it to the
masters and later in this video i'm
going to tell you more about how to
approach business in the right way where
it's long term and you make a lot of
money extra bonus point for free i'm
giving you a lot of value any numbers
you hear are usually just revenue and
because i had already built a million
dollar business it's not lying it's not
misleading it's just that most people
don't know that and i think it's
important to know so in case you didn't
know now you know and the last point a
lot of coaches and gurus i personally
know would lose their following if
people knew who they actually are
because they don't practice what they
preach and they oftentimes struggle with
the exact thing that they're teaching
about i know a world famous dating coach
who can't find a stable party
relationship coaches who are in toxic
relationships passive aggressive
spiritual coaches who have a huge e and
most how to make money online gurus only
started doing that because the business
they initially started didn't work out
and they failed miserably i remember
this guy who had an e-commerce business
and he was so bad at it making such dumb
mistakes and he had no clue what he was
doing me and my buddy felt pity for him
because we were absolutely crushing it
trying to help him
now he's wearing a suit and is a highly
paid business consultant
[Music]
and he's making a lot of money
now with all these wannabe experts out
there how do you know who to actually
trust see when i started my business
selling on amazon i consumed tons of
free information from podcasts youtube
videos blogs and while 95 of amazon
sellers i knew were not getting by i
grew to seven figures and eventually
signed a deal to sell my business for a
ton of cash after 18 months of making my
first sale the difference between me and
them was this they were listening to the
wrong people who gave bad advice while i
knew how to filter information to find
the best people out there who knew what
they were talking about and although the
experts they listened to had decades of
experience they sounded really smart and
they gave all the information for free i
knew it was bad advice because i
developed the skill of information
filtering and that made all the
difference here's how to do it it's my
secret 495.1 principle method
formula
don't take advice from anyone except me
whether it's free or paid until you know
what this is here's how it works four
percent of people giving advice is just
dirt it's horrible advice and sometimes
it's even dangerous luckily it's very
easy to identify because it's just
obvious we don't need to talk about it
like this guy who heals people by just
gazing at them
open yourself to be a conduit
for that energy
so beautiful
so next
next up it's 95 of experts who give you
clay advice which is advice that is not
bad kind of helpful you can build
something with it but it's not going to
last advice that is not bad is actually
really bad because it distracts you from
what really really matters and this is
what flipped people up see when i
started my own business in ecommerce
there were so many people that were
talking about what keywords to use in
the back end of your list how to change
the price depending on the time of the
day so you can make a few more sales
little hacks to save money on shipping
people thought wow this is great advice
so helpful it actually flipped up
because while they were busy doing all
this little stuff over here nobody
talked about what really mattered how do
you make an incredible product that
people really really want how do you
give so much to the customer that they
have no other choice than to buy more
from you most play advice is usually
just strategies and tactics they over
complicate things they focus on all
these little unnecessary details and
it's what you'll get in a lot of courses
you'll spend all this time implementing
their advice that only treats symptoms
but not the root causes then there's a
one percent of solid brick advice that
stands the test of time and allows you
to build something real
because i knew how to find that one
percent solid brick advice i dominated
the competition sold my business while
everyone else failed and had to pivot to
become a success coach while they were
taking the mediocre advice and focused
on the little details and little hacks
and tricks and tactics i spent way more
time building a better product i got
better reviews because of it and
investors wanted to buy my business the
tricky thing about this golden
information from the right people is
that it's extremely simple and boring
it's very hard to implement it takes a
long time but it holds exponential
results in the future it focuses on
fundamentals and principles the funny
thing is most people have already heard
this golden information they need to
hear but because it's boring and ah so
obvious they'll skip it because they're
distracted by all the 95 that doesn't
matter i know you have to make good
videos on youtube to succeed but i saw
in a video that if you have a great
intro it helps your branding
stop your videos suck make videos people
would click on make videos people would
watch to the end that's it i know i have
to become a mature and healthy
individual to attract the right person
but i heard of this secret text message
that makes her think that i'm confident
and then hey stop
no distraction now before i'm going to
tell you the most important thing you
need to know here's how to find more of
the one percent of people you can
actually trust number one they have
achieved what you want or even better i
recently attended a virtual conference
with mr beast the guy who has 45 million
subscribers and he knows youtube in and
out and his advice goes so much against
all this other stuff that you hear from
youtube consultants it's so simple
boring straightforward there's so much
misconception they focus on so much like
random stuff it's not as simple as just
make good videos that people enjoy and
click and watch you gotta factor in
comments i'm like what does that even
mean seriously i learned so much from
this guy and my channel will blow up
this year and you can already see the
results on my channel 300 views wow
number two they don't market their
service aggressively if you need to be a
great salesman to sell your product your
product sucks how come the tesla does no
advertising but everybody wants one
because the cars help the environment
the car can dance
and number three they don't need to
portray themselves as the experts
because they're already successful in
their field but here's the most
important thing that you need to know it
may be the most important skill as an
entrepreneur that separates the ones who
succeed from the ones who never make it
and then have to become a success guru
and the most successful people like elon
musk steve jobs jeff bezos they've all
mastered this skill it's this
independent thinking don't be a sheep
and always think for yourself question
everything and everyone the gurus the
experts the people exposing the experts
absolutely everyone the reason why
people listen to mediocre advice is
because they are so uncertain that they
want to have someone hold their hand all
the way but the people with the best nap
don't have time to hold your hand all
the way the more you can be comfortable
with being uncertain and moving forward
anyways the more happy and successful
you'll be
thanks for watching
[Music]
you